not even a persistent pre-dawn drizzle
could dampen the spirits of a clearly
triumphant Boris Johnson emerging from
Conservative Party headquarters in
London this is a stunning victory for
the Prime Minister and removes any
obstacle to him taking Britain out of
the European Union by the end of January
at his constituency count in Uxbridge
the Prime Minister was in a bully and
mood it does look as though this one
nation Conservative government has been
given a powerful new mandate to get
great [ __ ] done and not just to get
brexit done but to unite this country
and to take it forward and to focus on
the priorities of the British people the
first results came in traditional labour
strong halts in northeast England
dramatically reduced labour majorities
seemed to confirm the accuracy of the
exit poll result blithe Valley became
the first Labour seat to fall a 10
percent swing seeing the Conservatives
win there for the first time since 1957
[Applause]
across the map of Britain the trickle
became a torrent of constituencies
turning conservative blue traditional
labor seats like Workington and
Darlington Peterborough and red car
in contrast labor figures looked stunned
and disbelieving at the catastrophe
engulfing them the Labour leaders
position had already looked perilous as
the scale of the defeat began to sink in
Jeremy Corbyn bowed to the inevitable he
will not be leader for much longer I
will not lead the party in any future
general election campaign I will discuss
with our party to ensure there is a
process now of reflection on this result
and on the policies that the party will
take going forward it's been a bad night
for the Liberal Democrats - their leader
Joe Swinson unseated by the Scottish
National Party for millions of people in
our country these results will bring
dread and dismay and people are looking
for hope Boris Johnson fought this as a
brexit election and the simplicity of
the slogan get brexit done clearly
resonated with voters but some
commentators worry that politics is the
poorer because of it
Boris Johnson used all the tricks in the
book and I guess it's worked I worry
that every future political party will
say that's the way to do it if you want
to win and that actually over time or
undermine our democracy and our ability
to actually discuss big issues right now
though the size of his majority means
the Prime Minister has cleared the path
in front of him he can drive his own
agenda without fear opposition Paul
Brennan al-jazeera London let's take a
look at the current numbers with just
two seats still to be confirmed Boris
Johnson's Conservative Party has won an
outright majority in parliament with 363
seats the opposition Labour Party won
just two hundred and three seats the
Scottish National Party made major gains
with 48 seats the Liberal Democrats only
won 11 seats and their leader Joseph
Intan lost her seat to the SNP the
brexit party didn't win any seats and 23
seats have gone to others
while just a short time ago a jubilant
Boris Johnson said voters have delivered
a clear message with this mandate and
this majority we will at last be able to
do what pay attention this election
means that getting brexit done is now
the irrefutable irresistible unarguable
decision of the British people and with
this election I think we've put an end
to all those middle miserable threats of
a second referendum your hand may have
quivered over the ballot paper as before
you put your cross in the conservative
box and you may intend to return to
labour next time run and if that is the
case I am humbled that you have put your
trust in me and that you have put your
trust in us and I we will never take
your support for granted
[Applause]